oh baby sleeping
cardi b and offset's three-year-old
daughter culture is already the sweetest
big sister and her sibling hasn't even
been born yet she's so cute i love her
of course cardi and offset are expecting
baby number two together and on tuesday
the grammy winner filmed her little girl
as she tried to give the baby growing in
her belly a
oh toy sleeping
it's the shh
from culture for me
no baby sleeping
yeah baby's sleeping
give the turtle baby later okay
she's literally tiptoeing out of the
room guys
cute there's some big big things on the
way big bangs ever since the 28 year old
up rapper revealed she's having another
baby during her performance at the 2021
bet awards she's been giving fans an
inside look at her pregnancy oh to see
your stinky butt stinky butt on monday
cardi shared that clip of her hubby to
her insta story as they waited to see
the doctor
how to see your stinky butt stinky but
proud to see your stinky butt
so sleepy
and while the migos rapper may have been
sleepy once the dog came in the room and
offset saw his baby on the sonogram he
was wide awake and smiling ear to ear oh
yes honey last month the grammy winner
revealed her pregnancy cravings on her
insta story i don't really eat burgers
that much i used to eat a lot of burgers
when i was younger like a teenager in my
early 20s and now i'm back at it again
and oh yeah barbecue sauce barbecue meat
grilled meat is a real fat craving
baby and not only is she showing off
that growing baby bump on social media
she's flaunting it in her work too like
her video with lizzo for rumors partying
popping no that's the machine nobody
listen they buying them streams they've
been posted on vlogs overseas and when
it comes to being a mom the new york
native told et back in 2019 it means
everything to her
what does it mean to be a mother
it means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's indescribable
it's like
like
love joy it's a
switch
you know what i'm saying it's like a
automatic smile so it's everything
everything yeah
[Music]
you